telles maladies vénériennes
bernard pivot
dans quelques jours ce sera votre tour
d'effectuer un grand come back sur
antenne j'ai été très frappé par le
manque de retentissement qu'a eu la mort
de raymond l'hiver vous voulez dire que
vous allez faire une émission sur
vraiment oliver non non pas du tout mais
je veux tenir ma promesse faire une
émission de caractère culturel pour un
large public
alors je vais donc faire une émission
sur la cuisine et la gastronomie
d'ailleurs le titre est trouvée bouillon
de culture est un titre premier degré
alors j'ai hésité longtemps entre
bouillon de culture et culture du
bouillon mais je crois si si vous êtes
de mon avis il me semble que culture du
bouillon s'appliquerait mieux à
l'ensemble des programmes de la deuxième
chaîne mais je lis ici que dans votre
projet le bouillon apparaît comme le
plat principal
ah oui ah oui oui non mais ça c'est vrai
parce que dans la cuisine d'aujourd'hui
tout s'organise autour du bouillon de la
soupe du potage d'ailleurs je j'avais
pensé à me ment intitulé cette émission
papotage de culture mais bon
même si ça les fait un peu rire là c'est
c'était un petit peu trop aux parisiens
et intello et qui seront les invités
alors dans la première partie des
personnalités des artistes des vedettes
des stars chacune vient avec sa recette
qu'elle défend et elle descend en
flammes les recettes des autres qu'elle
a goûté au corps enfin peu importe nous
avons fait une émission pilote sur les
moules de bouchot avec vanessa paradis
et françoise sagan et malheureusement
j'ai pu constater que jean pierre
chevènement digérait mal les moules de
bouchot comme à votre habitude vous
voulez faire une émission proche du
public
c'est une évidence mais je me demande si
je lis ici je me demande si vous n'avez
pas dû intituler vous n'auriez pas dû
intituler votre émission 50 millions de
consommateurs de bouillon pour l'audimat
ce serait peut-être pas mal non et dans
la deuxième partie de l'émission
alors là là je vais accueillir les
grands auteurs les les bons écrivains du
moment pour tout vous dire ce que j'aime
vraiment lire alors donc jacques huret
l'aller les bocuse les trois gros les
léguer rares les seins de reims les
georges blanc les paul loup sulitzer
attendez j'ai pas bien compris vous
venez de citer plus solidaire dans cette
liste de grands oui ben oui oui donc
voilà bon ça peut vous étonner est tout
à fait vrai que bocuse est un bien
meilleur écrivain que je prends par
exemple mcdonald's du roi con
au sully d'isère où gharbi c'est bon ça
me paraît évident mais ce qui me semble
rapprocher bocuse et solidaire c'est
l'usagé qu'ils font l'un et l'autre
d'une brigade à l'intérieur de la
cuisine littéraire et avec un premier
chef et dans le cas de ce leader il
s'agit de loup durand et alors
aurons-nous en exclusivité les recettes
de paul solitaire évidemment évidemment
vous aurez par exemple le pôle louhans
krauth vous aurez le loup durand le broc
le loup durand flambée aux herbes de
provence
vous aurez aussi le prof j'aimerais bien
aussi
oui le peul ou en papillote mais alors
servi avec un petit beurre blanc mais
alors très réduits ou est très léger
très retenu 1
et puis vous aurez aussi le loup durand
avec de la crème et des lentilles vertes
vous aurez aussi le leupolu demi deuil
etc etc
enfin de l'eau à la bouche mais bon
dernière question est ce que il y aura
comme dans apostrophe des spéciales
évidemment non seulement il y aura des
spéciales dire aussi des marraines des
baux longs et d'éclairs ce que j'espère
voyez vous c'est avec bouillon de
culture faire la cuisine du marché et
surtout obtenir pour antenne 2 des parts
de marché bernard thibault mercier
voilà